- Are you someone who's
crazy about Christmas?
- I love Christmas, I get--
(crowd cheering)
Yeah!
- Did you have a favorite
present, growing up?
Like for Christmas?
I have one.
- Oh, you do?
- My first song I ever
wrote on was my key--
We didn't have any money
and my mom pulled together,
totally on credit,
and got me a keyboard.
- That's nice.
I think that my family
did give me a little
sing-along microphone thing,
but then they were like,
"Forget that, that's not gonna work out."
Every year I wanted baby dolls.
I really always wanted a baby doll,
and then one year the
hot, cool doll of the year
was this baby called Baby Feels So Real.
And you would touch the baby
and would have bones and stuff in it!
Do you guys remember this?
I don't know why I remember that doll,
'cause that's creepy.
- That's...
My daughter ha--
- Who was like, "We should make a doll,
"and put bones in it."
- Yeah
- "and give it to children."
- My daughter has a creepy doll.
She has a creepy doll that she loves,
and I'm always trying to misplace it...
- Let's put that away.
- And she's like, "Where's my doll?"
- Yeah, and you're like, "No."
- It's super creepy,
it looks like it's from
a haunted horror movie,
kinda thing.
But that's okay.
- Yeah, I had a lot of those,
I had a doll too
where you had to teach it to learn words.
So I'd be like, "It's apple."
Or like, "Spaghetti."
And it'd be like, "Asghetti."
And I'd be like, "No! It's spaghetti!"
Like over and over.
- You'd argue?
- And then they'd get it right
and I was like, "I just
taught that doll a word."
- "I'm gonna be a great mom."